they all get brandon woodruff the
all-star tim he has had such a great
first half of this season
2-2
goes with it to left field
down base hit
a winker long a b stay hot strength on
strength castellanos clubs fastballs
and he turns on that one
well hit to left and it's off the wall
winker sprinting to third stop sign is
on castellanos cruises into second he
mashes a double to the wall and the reds
have second and third with one out and
now vato with runners at second and
third and only one out as the reds try
to strike early against the right-hander
brandon woodruff up and in target turn
on it club it to center field
winker scores stop sign for castellanos
a scolded single up the box joey votto
connects and the reds get on the board
in the first inning one to nothing
coming right out of the on deck circle
ready to swing the bat
that one's hit towards the second
baseman peterson goes to second one on
to first got a double play
just what woodruff needed not hard hit
but a perfect turn peterson and adamus
lead in hand luis castillo prepares and
in the last eight games he's been really
good
2-2
swing and a miss he struck him out
this pitch starts in the middle and it
drops straight down almost split
finger-esque
thomas way out in front as woodruff
prepares to face his fellow pitcher
castillo
has four hits making five this season
oh the reds pitchers
miley this series
castillo with his fifth poke of the
campaign
two on two out oh two from brandon
woodruff
got him
three straight hooks
first strikeout for brandon woodruff
strands a couple of reds brewers back to
work on offense
[Music]
swing and a miss strike three second k
for castillo
peterson with another walk shocker
on base chase
skied
right center castellano slows makes the
catch brewers stranded a pair castillo
and the reds in front by a rump
oh and he sticks that heater up and in
on yelich caught looking strike three
adamus
suarez
hyper efficient inning
high moon shots and line drives for home
runs
opposite way down base hit the growing
legacy of tyler stevenson
here's the pitch from woodruff swing and
a miss got him this time another
fastball this one at 95. looks at suarez
at second and the o2
and a little flare to short adamus is
there to squeeze it for the final out of
the inning
towards the middle base hit
second hit of the game for the brewers
he draws a walk
stevenson castillo both started walking
towards the reds dugout tolez with a
great at bat there to draw the walk
and it's a walk
and they're going to be loaded for
brandon woodward
here's the 1-2 pitch swing and a miss
struck him out a fast ball over the
outer half woodruff swings right through
it the inning is over
the brewers load the bases in the fourth
and leave them loaded
got him looking 97 on the edge just the
second strike out of the ball game for
brandon woodruff
[Applause]
a couple of strikeouts in the inning for
brandon woodruff
[Music]
swing and a miss struck him out five k's
for castillo
this one headed towards center of bay
set
top spin ground ball from christianity
she's on runner goes
it's outside for ball four
another walk issued by luis castillo the
wheels are turning for david bell
castillo checked second the pitch and
it's lined right back to him he makes
the catch flips tavato at first and they
double off adamus oh my goodness a
rocket right back into the glove of
castillo
and the reds get a big time double play
to get out of the threat
stevenson slaps this one into right
center second hit of the day
for tyler stevenson
and now nine hits against woodruff it's
the most that he has ever allowed in a
home game
now woodruff deals again and
suarez bounces to third to second one
and the relay in time to double him up
that's what we're talking about nine
hits don't mean a thing
swing and a miss luis castillo six
strikeouts today
he just took another walk here
tying runnings on
well that's all for castillo not quite
crisp and he's throwing a three-hitter
leaving with the lead in the shutout the
left-handed amir garrett is on for the
reds runner takes off
it's a strike through the second not in
time just peterson swipes the bat
nothing you do about that jase peterson
gets his fifth stolen base well jackie
bradley jr now against the lefty
jackie bradley jr through the right side
peterson around third castiano's throw
cutoff tiger two strike base hit by jbj
how big was the stolen base
and
the payoff again swinging a miss struck
him out of fastball over the outside
edge and garrett strikes out reyes to
end the sixth foxberger took over the
seventh and he has not looked back since
here's the one-two to winker swinging a
miss he strikes out winker and he
strikes out to side
[Applause]
in field heavily tilted
didn't quite have the handle there as
we're gonna get a medical visit here
after that bad
bad miss
but hopefully he's going to be okay
that's not
not good to come out in the middle of an
inning sean doolittle is on he'll have
as much time as he needs
shallow pop up right field long run base
head
can't believe that one fell
freddie peralta said put it in your
pocket
runner goes
stevenson's throw not in time
adamus steals second base freeman
asking the reds to check adam has slid
into the foot of freeman does his foot
pop off as freeman is applying the tag
now the umpires are going to go review
it with the folks back in new york
headsets off of the call
out
i mean you just never know you know
nobody knows
craig council is speaking for everybody
same with lily adonis
payoff
bottle
diving spear peterson has no play and
joey votto's got a second base hit go
ahead run is on against the mighty devin
williams
does his job here ground ball to first
hero takes care of it it's a zero for
devin williams
farmer
to deep right center field
hopping miss
garcia missed it suarez late break just
gets to second base
a whiff by a leaping avissael garcia and
the reds have two aboard with nobody out
payoff pitch
inside he walks it bases loaded one out
what an eye for jonathan india and now
it's up to nick castellanos 1-0 he
swings ground ball in center field base
hit suarez scores right on his heels
former crosses liam castillanos loving
it
dad the hero
and all-star to all-star he pushes the
reds ahead popping josh hayder 3-1
cincinnati
louie by a two-run lead
and a team
whose fight
has been contagious
inspirational and darn fun ground ball
shortstop farmer
and the cincinnati reds
beat the brewers in milwaukee they take
the series claiming three of four and
they roll into the all-star break having
closed ground on the first place brewers
their deficit sits at four just three in
the loss column